welcome everyone
is this thing on hello
perfect
i'm really happy to see so many
javascript developers in here excited
about the new async and awaits someone's
leaving i'm kidding this is c sharp i
promise
someone actually left so i really hope
they're coming back
all right so we're going to be talking
about efficient async and awaits
and how to kind of use the best
practices when you're building c-sharp
applications
efficiency can mean quite a lot of
things it can mean that we want to build
applications that perform really fast or
really good for our end users it can
mean that we are efficient in terms of
building code faster and making sure
that we follow the best practices to
ensure that the applications aren't
crashing on us
we are going to cover a few of these
different things in this talk and
hopefully by the end of this you will
have some some goodies that you can
bring back to your applications and make
sure that you're using async and away
properly in your apps
my name is phil beckberg i've done a few
talks on c sharp i have a book on c
sharp i have a course on pluralsight so
check that out if you like any of my
stuff and you can ping me on twitter if
you have any questions
or just shout out i still have a little
bit of a bad hearing so
i if i can't hear it's not that i'm
ignoring you just ping me on twitter if
i if i can't get your question now
so i guess the question is why would we
bother at all introducing asynchronous
principles in an application
really it boils down to the fact that we
want to avoid this type of behavior we
have an application this is an android
application and i'm not specifically
saying that all android apps are
unreliable but in this case i built an
application for for ndc london that when
you click the button the application
felt like it was crashing or the os told
me that this application is no longer
responding
so the idea is that we want to bring in
asynchronous principles to ensure that
we can avoid these types of unreliable
scenarios
so one of the efficient approaches is to
you know improve the user experience i
want the application to feel as
efficient as possible for my end users
just because the operating system is
telling me that something might be
taking a little bit too long of a time
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
application isn't doing some heavy work
just means that we're doing the work on
the wrong place
and also when it comes to mobile
applications we need to keep in mind
that we shouldn't overuse asynchronous
programming or parallel programming
because every operation on a mobile
application requires battery and cpu
power so that's something we should keep
in the back of our heads
if you go over to the pc world
or mac world for the for that matter um
we want to make sure that we can use all
the resources that we have available
this is a my my workstation at home
which is pretty powerful i have a lot of
cpu i have a lot of ram and pretty good
fasts internet speed and good hard
drives so it may be able to leverage all
those different types of resources
and that boils down to two different
types of paradigms we can talk about cpu
bound and i o bound operations
in dot net there these are approached
the same way but they are fundamentally
different
cpu bound operations that's parallel
programming where you want to divide a
problem into really small pieces and
solve them independently where they have
really nothing in common
io bound operations could be loading a
really large file into memory which then
later process in parallel
so you can combine these two paradigms
as well which is where it becomes a
little bit confusing but with the help
of net and something called the task
parallel library we can make this work a
little bit easier and we're going to be
looking at quite a few examples of that
as well
so in this example here i'm just loading
some really large chunk of data which i
think can process in parallel
but it really boils down to one simple
notion of what i want to do i want to go
from something that blocks my user
interface or blocks my application
it doesn't make a lot of sense to maybe
introduce async and wait in a console
application it makes more sense to do
this in applications that have a user
interface
so i want to take my application from
feeling like it's blocking my user from
input to something that feels a little
bit better i can allow my users to do
more things at the same time
and the way that i do that is by move
all the work that i'm doing on the ui
thread
i want to avoid doing heavy lifting on
the ui thread or the main thread of the
application
in the past this has been rather
difficult to do in a good way because
you had to do
use threadings manually but now we have
apis in in.net to do this a little bit
easier
and one thing i want to want you to keep
in mind is that you should never block
in a synchronous operation so once
you've said that i want to run this
somewhere else never force that to give
you a result there are proper ways to
ask for if there is a result available
but you never force it to give you some
data unless you know it's completed
might sound a little bit obvious but
we're going to look at a few examples of
that as well where we crash an
application because we're using it
improperly
so really if i look back at that
nice android application really what i
want to do is i want to take this
blocking ui that where the os is telling
me that something's crashing and i want
to prompt the user with another type of
blocking to tell them that well you
should wait for a little bit longer
psychologically this means that the user
knows that the application is still
doing something
i'm providing them feedback that the
application isn't crashing
although we all know that if we see this
please wait dialogue for too long we're
going to end up killing the application
anyways because we don't really want to
wait
so there are other ways to approach this
as well but this is just one of the
ideas behind why we want to make our
user interfaces a little bit better
and to do this we want to introduce the
task parallel library
this was added in.net 4.5
and the whole idea is to simplify
working with concurrent and asynchronous
code
it's kind of the definition of the task
parallel library so they group these two
different paradigms together where we
have concurrent code which is parallel
programming where we solve small pieces
of
problems in smaller pieces and do that
as fast as possible using every
available resource
and then we have asynchronous
programming which is a little bit
different it's also about offloading
work to a different thread or a
different something else that's not
blocking my user
interface but then when there's a result
available or when that operation has
completed i wants to be notified
think of a callback i want to be
notified when there's some data that i
can process
and to introduce this in a c-sharp
application or any dot net application
it's really simple
it all starts with task.run
this does a lot of things behind the
scenes where it tries to figure out
where to put your work it schedules your
work to run on a different thread it may
reuse threads if there's one that's
available so it doesn't have to do
unnecessary allocations so there's a lot
of things that happening here that we
probably should keep in mind as well
the idea is that work is distributed
somewhere else to different threads so
it doesn't block
our current context
context is that thread as well they're
kind of used interchangeably
then one of the interesting things with
this task parallel library is that
threads on the thread pool can be reused
for different tasks now normally when
you do thread.start or new thread that
actually gives you a new thread that
it's not reused there's no data
available in that particular context but
with tasks you may have data that's
coming from another synchronous
operation that you've done in before
because it's reusing data so there might
be threads static data that's still
available on a new task and that can be
a little bit confusing
so with that given you shouldn't use
thread static data at all when you do
async and awaits or taskbar library
and what also allows you to do when you
do task.run it actually gives you
something called a task back and you can
use this to figure out if there's a
result available you can subscribe to
when it's completed this is known as
introducing something called a
continuation so once i've started my
asynchronous operation that could be
loading a file from disk or
querying a database or something like
that
when that's completed i can go back to
that place where i was before
and i can continue doing my work
all without blocking my user for doing
additional things in my application
and of course this here also allows us
to return data as i mentioned it
wouldn't be
so useful if we were only able to
offload work somewhere else and not
being able to ask for data back
now the task here is in fact generic but
you don't have to explicitly determine
which return type it has
that's in fact inferred by the compiler
so
let's jump out of powerpoint for a
moment
and jump into visual studio
and i have this application if i run
this this is a wpf application just for
for simplicity
it could be any type of ui application
really
just an easy way to illustrate why
synchronous programming is important
when i click run here this application
locks up and if this were locking up for
a little bit longer windows would have
told me that this application is no
longer responding
but i don't know that i don't know that
it's not doing a lot of work
so let's have a look at what this code
is actually doing you don't have to know
much about wpf to understand this
but basically we have a click event
handler that's calling a method called
do something
so far so good and then we have this
method here called dual something
which is simply updating the ui with
some information and then we have a
thread out sleep for two seconds
normally we only add thread out sleep
when we want to solve random problems
actually we shouldn't do that but
sometimes it does solve
interesting
race conditions
but let's just say that this simulates a
little bit of work it could be loading
something from a web api or loading
something from a store that's cold
storage for instance
what i want to do now is i want to say i
want to run this work somewhere else i
have two different ways to do this
either i run this entire method
in a task
like this here i could say task.run
and task.run takes an action which is
just a delegate so it could pass a
reference to that method to say run this
method somewhere else i don't care just
run this and hopefully now my
application is a lot better but if i run
the application now without the debugger
attached
i can move my window around it didn't
lock up but also
the ui didn't update after those two
seconds so now i've introduced a bug in
the application
and even though the application feels
more efficient it's a lot more faster
the user will think it's awesome because
it's it's no longer crashing on them but
it's not working as expected
the problem is i'm trying to update the
ui from a different thread
now this is where it becomes a little
bit tricky because now i have to
communicate back to the ui that i'm i
need to
update the ui
from a totally different thread and to
do that i can ask for
for the the context
that owns the ui thread to invoke work
on that
let me just show you what this looks
like and you'll understand why this is a
little bit i don't use the word nasty
but it doesn't look very pretty
so i can say that i need to invoke some
work
on the ui thread
this is very very wpf specific each ui
framework has its own way of doing this
but basically you have to
have to then invoke the ui when that's
done a better approach would probably
have been to move those two seconds
worth of work to a separate thread
instead of moving this entire method and
wrapping this synchronous call i would
say in a whole task.run a much better
approach would be to undo this
and look at this in a little bit of a
different manner
this is one of the things you should
avoid doing you shouldn't just simply
wrap your synchronous operations in new
tasks you should go to the root of the
problem the problem here
isn't the call to do something it's in
fact what it's doing internally so we
have to drill down here and figure out
how do we move this
to a different thread
right
something like this here
so now what happens here is that if i
run this
the application is going to behave a lot
better but it didn't take two seconds
before i got the result from philip
because
actually what we're doing now
is that i'm saying run the method do
something update the ui
then run some work on a different thread
then immediately run this line of code
here at the bottom
right so just offload those two seconds
worth of work but what if this thing
here at the bottom relies on the result
of this
operation now this here introduces that
asynchronous operation which means that
i can subscribe to when this is done
i can say that i want to get the result
of this
let's say task
and i could say that i want to continue
result task
i could say that after this work is done
i want to continue doing some other work
like this here so now what happens is
that after two seconds have been
operated on a different thread i want to
go ahead and update the ui
and if i run this without the debugger
we're going to get hello from ndc or
hello ndc but the second line never
shows up
this is because with the task parallel
library all the continuations are
executed on a different thread as well
it could be that it's executed in line
with this thread here or this task
it really depends on how you configure
that
and the the runtime is pretty smart
enough to try and do some really smart
optimization for you
so again if i want to update the ui from
this place i'd have to introduce the
dispatcher
and now we've made the code a little bit
sorry we've made the code
on unreadable
but at least we've introduced a
synchronous programming
so now hopefully after two seconds this
is now going to update the ui so i've
solved one problem but
even though the application feels a
little bit more efficient
this code here is not going to be very
efficient to work with
it's very very fragile it's very easy
for me to make the mistake of not
introducing this cross threading to talk
back to the ui thread
there has to be a way for us to work
with this in a better approach
and of course there is we're going to
look at async and await which hopefully
solves all our problems
but first we have to understand exactly
what happens here
one thing that you didn't notice because
i didn't run this with the
debugger attached if i take this line of
code here and run this without the
dispatcher
and i'm going to run this with the
debugger because that's going to capture
all the exceptions that happens
when i debug the application
i'm going to click
on run here and hopefully
after two seconds it's going to tell us
that we in fact had
an exception
so this there was an exception thrown
inside this continuation because it
couldn't up the ui from a thread that
wasn't owned by the ui trying to do
cross threading without that dispatcher
nastiness that i had to add for wpf
but how come the application didn't
crash here
it's because
tasks in general
they will
capture all your exceptions
or they will swallow your exceptions so
if there's an exception even if i have
an exception inside if this
this operation if i replace this with a
throw new exception that would in fact
just
not do anything the application wouldn't
crash because that exception would live
on this this instance of the task here
so how do we check if there's an
exception
well you'd have to do that inside one of
these continuations
so you could say if results task
is faulted and you can then grab the
exception to check that
all right so
that's not too bad
but how do i know if this continuation
failed well this also returns a task so
you'd have to say
this task dot continue with
this takes the task
and then you'd have to check if this is
faulted
get the idea right
t is faulted and so forth
and then to check if that is faulted
you'd have to add another continuation
and so forth
it doesn't get very pretty right
so this is all the way back in dotnet
4.5 and
prior to adding async in a weight but
it's important to understand how all of
this works because async and away uses
this internally quite heavily actually
it it's built on this so if you don't
understand the fundamentals of the tasks
it may become really hard to efficiently
add async and weight in your
applications and use that in the best
approach
all right so
there's one more thing i want to show
you here actually
before we go ahead and and talk about
async and wait
let's say that
we'll get rid of
a little bit of code here
here we go
let's say that instead of of having the
test text from philip
said here let's say that we returned
this
from this task up here after those two
seconds i want to return that from this
asynchronous operation now to access
this result
i have to do that inside the
continuation
inside the continuation is the only
place you're ever allowed to do your
task.result because you know you have a
result here calling this property is in
fact a blocking operation so if there's
not a result available it will block the
entire thread until that's available
that means if we were to do that
like this here our result is equal to
task.result
looks the same but it's really not what
this does here is that this is going to
block the ui thread the current thread
is going to be locked until that result
is available unless it already completed
all right so and this here is now going
to be turned into a task of t result or
task of string
all right so
with a little bit of an understanding of
the tasks and how you add that
a few considerations that you should
keep in mind you should be careful when
you wrap code inside your tasks or using
task.run because that can be a little
bit problematic
as we just saw here it might seem like
the application runs really quickly but
we introduced a few bugs and unless we
capture all those exceptions or have the
debugger attached we won't know
and i didn't show this but thread static
data
is unreliable you can use something
called async local if you really have to
have static data inside your tasks
but if you do need to do that i would
recommend you read up on async local
and then another consideration with
tasks is that we should always validate
the tasks
and that means we should always check
that if there was an exception or not
and with the task parallel library that
becomes a little bit tedious because you
have to add continuation after
continuation after continuation and that
doesn't look very pretty
so hopefully we can solve this a little
bit better with async and a weight
before we get into 1808 i just want to
show you this little portion of code as
well parallel.4 is it's also part of the
task parallel library but that's a
blocking call which means that to
to solve your problem in parallel this
here is going to run from 0 to 100
or it's zero to 99
um
and that's actually going to use your
current thread as well to solve the same
problem so if you want to offload that
to somewhere else to not block the ui
thread you always have to wrap your
parallel for loops or parallel for each
loops in a separate task
all right
let's talk about async and wait
these two keywords were introduced quite
a while ago but still one of those
things that people tend to get a little
bit wrong and it's really easy to get it
wrong as well because the the designers
of this feature made it really easy to
add it anywhere
without a lot of implications
so these are just contextual keywords
which means that they do a lot of
compiler magic to solve the same
problems that
we could do without async and await but
they do add a lot of code behind the
scenes and we should understand exactly
what what that is so when we add async
and await the idea is that all the
complexity that we just saw with the
continuation and all of that it's going
to hide that somewhere else
hiding complexity is always a good idea
because the code becomes a much easier
to work with but it's also a little bit
more fragile
so it promotes readability it makes the
code easier to read
you no longer have this nested calls or
you these this looks like an arrow in
your application but instead it look
very fluent you read it from top to
bottom you quite understand exactly
what's going to happen
but one issue is that it's a little bit
more error-prone
and that's because it hides the
complexity it's in something called a
state machine
so how do we add this to an application
well it all starts with the the async
keyword
this very simple method here returns a
task you can see that it doesn't
actually return a task anywhere because
the compiler takes care of that for us
so adding the async keyword does a lot
of magic behind the scenes
but i guess the question is
does this make the code asynchronous can
we use this all alone without doing
anything else and the answer to that is
no
the async keyword alone doesn't do
anything in particular other than
introducing a lot of complexity and it
moves your entire method body into a
generated class
but it doesn't run anything on a
separate thread
that all that all that's all done by
this task a delay here
so when i introduce
task delay
that's
you know doing some work somewhere else
it could be an http call it could be in
a web
loading something from disk
this way just simulate some work
and you use that together with the away
keyword so these two keywords should
always be used together
um
the reason you're you're allowed to use
async alone is for for i guess virtual
methods and all of that and you where
you don't have the method body it plays
i don't know they've just introduced
that i believe they should have made it
so that you have to
always use them together
anyways the there's a lot of things
happening here once first thing it moves
this method body to a different class
the weight keyword is now in charge of
making sure that the code at the bottom
is executed
only when that asynchronous operation is
completed
so the await keyword
is now what marks for something known as
the continuation you know that continue
with method call that we had earlier
we no longer have the method call but
it's still the same concept
internally it's going to use that
continue with method
to run the code after the await keyword
sort of it has a lot of more code than
that but basically it does that
it's also making sure that it validates
the success or failure of the task
so we no longer have to check if it's
faulted on our own
this will in fact validate the entire
chain so you no longer have to continue
with and check the default state and all
of that nastiness that we had to do
earlier
what it also does it does as when it
reaches the await keyword it returns to
whoever called the method and this is
where it becomes a little bit tricky to
understand because what happens
i'll go back here just to show you this
portion of the code here
when it reaches the await keyword it
returns to whoever called run async
right because it can't run the final
code because that's inside the
continuation
so whoever called run async will then be
be able to execute the next lines
all right so always use them together
that's that's really really important
so let's have a look at how we can make
our code a little bit better
here we go
so instead of having all of this code
here let's let's now introduce async and
wait and see how this is going to behave
a little bit different
i really don't like this this whole idea
of having to
use continue with but instead
i still have to move the work to a
different thread by doing task.run
right
but i don't like this
so instead what i want to do
i like to await the task
and then i'd like to update the ui
we no longer have the result task so
that would be task.result instead but as
i mentioned earlier we should avoid
using dot result
we could use dot result here because i
know that it's been it's been properly
we've awaited the task which means that
what happens here is that
it's not going to run that portion of
the code before it actually has a result
available
but the best practice is not to do like
that so what can we do instead to get
the result out of the task so the await
keyword it validates that we have
a not not a faulty task there's no
exceptions
but it also gives us the result
and then i can use this here at the
bottom and we can see here that this
here
is a string
so what a weight does is that it makes
sure that
there's no exceptions exceptions and
then it grabs any results out of that
task so it would get the test text from
philip and i already had the async
keyword here at the top which
i shouldn't have had
but
as you'll see here i get
a little bit of a
squiggle here telling me that you can't
use the await keyword
you cannot use the await operator or
keyword without the async keyword but
you can have a method call with the
async keyword without using a weight
so now if i just
add the async keyword here
and i'll run the application i will just
make sure that it still works the same
as before
i can run this here i can move the
window around and after two seconds it
says hello ndc from philip
so
now that i've added this here i said
earlier that when it reaches this await
keyword it in fact
goes back to whoever calls this method
so if we look at where this is called
this is called from a click event
handler
it calls do something that means that
when it reaches that
await keyword we should be back
at this line here
so if i do
debug.txt plus is equal to
test or waiting maybe better
let's do that
and i'll run this here
hopefully it's going to say hello ndc
and then test. and then after that it's
going to top it with the rest of the
text
so what actually happened here is that
if we step through this it's going to
call do something
that updates the ui
that offloads some work to somewhere
else using the task parallel library
and then it sees the await keyword now
what this does is that it validates that
there was no exceptions so if there's an
exception in here
throw new exception
like this here this will be thrown back
to whoever calls this method and they
can handle that
or in fact it will be thrown back to
whoever uses the await keyword so when
we have the await here we have the
option of wrapping this in a try catch
block to make sure that we can catch any
potential exceptions
right
and then after that it's
when it sees the white keyword it
returns back to run this code here and
then the user can update the ui and
click around and do whatever they want
then after two seconds
it runs this code here
so what happens now if i if i run this
here obviously i have a throw new
exception the application is going to
crash
that's no good so i want to handle this
but if i don't know what happens inside
this method i just know that this is an
asynchronous method what happens if i
wrap this in a try and catch block
run this without the debugger
hopefully now this application works as
it should and i click run here and
the application works but it doesn't
for some reason
the application still crashes
if i run it with the debugger attached
and i'll put a break point in this
catch block here
click run
we can see that i did get the
exception and it's it's validated by
this await keyword here that inside the
task there was an exception you we
caught that and it's now going to be
thrown back to whoever calls this method
but then suddenly i'm somewhere else
and the application didn't
actually catch this
so the problem here is that
i would need to validate that this
method also worked properly
does that mean i can just add since it's
an async method could i just add the the
await keyword in front of that
let's try that and see what happens
if i do await it's going to tell me that
this method is not marked as async so i
have to do that first
but there's still a little bit of an
issue here
because
we cannot await a method that's void it
doesn't return anything so how would it
await that how would it know that this
is an asynchronous operation
so for the consumer of the method do
something
this here doesn't in fact do anything
more than just run some code that
doesn't return anything so in order for
me to be able to track this work and to
capture any potential exceptions
it also needs to return a task
this is why you should never do async
void because async void doesn't allow
you to track when work is completed it
doesn't allow you to know when data has
been available or when the operations
are completed
but fortunately for us there's an easy
way to fix this
i can change this to async task and i
don't have to do anything else the
compiler takes care of all of that for
us
so what happened now there's actually a
few things that is going on here not
only did it change what this method
returns it automatically returned a task
from this here
but since this returns a task it also
means that any exceptions that happens
inside this method
is now going to be be put on the task
that this returns
and that can be a little bit confusing
as well
so if i didn't have this await keyword
here
i wouldn't be able to capture any
exceptions and you'll see that if i run
this with the debugger attached
i click run here we can see that since i
have the debugger it knows that i have
an exception
but then it didn't enter this this
this catch block here because if i don't
await this it doesn't validate that
there was no exceptions
so let's add a weight back here
and now hopefully the application
behaves a little bit better
i get the exception and i'm inside my
catch block so this here just shows you
that it's
it's not as simple as just adding the
async in a way keyword as soon as you
have a task or it's not as easy as just
adding tasks that run whenever you want
to run something somewhere else
there's quite a lot of things that you
need to keep in mind
adding these keywords may seem very easy
at just as a first glance but they do
quite a lot behind the scenes
and that's kind of the next part i want
to talk about
so
understanding just the asynchronous
keywords in the task parallel library
that's great but you also really need to
understand
what happens when you add the keywords
what's generated by by these keywords to
fully appreciate what they're doing
and what's happening when you add the 18
keyword
it introduces something called a state
machine the state machine keeps track of
all the asynchronous code that's being
executed and all the work that's
happening on different threads
now the state machine is it's really
just a
a piece of code that's asking are we
there yet it checks if you have any
asynchronous operations that are running
it keeps track of which continuation to
run in next
and it's pretty clever what it's doing
is that it has this really big code that
says run this asynchronous operation
when that's done do this do this do this
and then it adds itself onto the
continuation of the next running task so
it always runs itself whenever the next
asynchronous operation is completed
and what it's also doing is that it
handles all the potential results and
the exceptions so as you saw here i was
able to capture the exception when i
added the task as a return type
but it also crashed my entire
application when it found an exception
and i used the await keyword this is
because the state machine just handles
all of those different cases for us
and it's going to be smart enough to be
able to handle
some really smart context switches and
make sure that sometimes it run codes
inline because that's faster so even
though it generates a bunch of code it's
going to do its best to do that as
efficiently as possible
and obviously a state machine makes sure
that it executes all the code after the
await keyword
the whole idea of adding the away
keyword is so that we can run code when
an asynchronous operation is done and
this whole thing that's generated help
us do that
so when we add this async keyword it
generates this entire state machine
that really means that it moves entire
method body into somewhere else
and it's really good to understand that
there's a lot of code involved in doing
this
so even though i have a really simple
method here with very very little code
when i compile this and it has the async
keyword at the top here
this doesn't no longer look anything
like when this isn't compiled
it no longer looks anything like what i
had earlier
there's no async keyword because the
async keyword doesn't exist inside the
clr the runtime doesn't know anything
about anything can wait
so it has to use async and away
internally or or the the concept of
the taskbar library internally and
threading so it generates a state
machine it does a lot of things with
that it starts it and then you see here
at the bottom
it returns a reference to the state
machine's task so whoever calls the
method run async can now keep track of
exactly what's happening which
asynchronous operation is running are
there any exceptions are there any
results available
and if we drill into this state machine
here
and just look at exactly what's
happening here we can see that there's
some if we just go back here there's var
x is equal to 10 there's a task.delay
and then debug.writeline so let's see if
we can find that inside this portion of
the code here
here's the
the x is equal to 10
task delay and then at the bottom here
we have the the debug at writeline
so this here is inside the state machine
and this is kind of a
i wouldn't say a loop because it's
really not it adds itself on to the
continuation of the next running task so
it runs this portion of the code for
every time it completes and it uses the
wonderful keyword go to to make this
this work
i haven't used that one
myself in a very long time but it's used
very cleverly inside the state machine
here
so we have the the task.delay it checks
if it's completed if it's not it just
returns
so it can run some code after this here
because in fact what happens here is
that all of this code
is executed
on i'll show you here
we go into visual studio
all of the code here the fact that
debug.txt plus sql to hello ndc worked
is because this code here is still
executed on the calling thread it's
executed on the ui thread so if this
call originates from the click event
handler like we have here
i'm calling do something there's nothing
here that offloads any work to a
different thread
until we have the task.run
then after task.run we're back
at the ui thread it sees this await
keyword
and then it adds this to its
continuation
so it makes sure that it can do all of
this context switching but it's also
important to know and understand that
all the coding here is executed on
the thread that calls it
so if i were to have a thread dot sleep
here
this would still block the ui thread
even though i have the async keyword and
even though the code was moved into a
generated state machine there's nothing
here that just magically makes this
faster and runs somewhere else
right
i think it's worth mentioning that we
shouldn't use async void
it's it's really it's it's worth
emphasizing that you should avoid that
as much as you can
and as we see here
the problem is that we have no way of
tracking that this work is done as you
see here at the bottom it doesn't return
any
doesn't return any reference at all so
when that method is is compiled we have
no way of tracking the state machine and
its work or getting those exceptions
there's no way around or recovering from
potential exceptions
and that's not very efficient
that means that
i wouldn't want to drive a car that was
built on.net where they use async void
let's just leave it at that
so it's an easy fix really we just
change a little slight change here look
here at the top here instead of having
async void we have asynctask and even
though this here is a very very
slight
change it kind of has a big impact as
well because now we are asking whoever
consumes this method to also validate
that it completed successfully
and we saw an example of this
just a moment ago um
so let's talk about deadlocks which is
also one of the the things that people
tend to run into
or not being able to run out of rather
what happens with deadlocks is that you
end up in a situation where there's no
way to recover from you have one thread
waiting for another and that sounds
like a very distant problem but when but
when you do multi-threaded or
asynchronous programming it's really
just one method call away
i'm going to show you a pretty
pretty
bad example
or another bad example but one that
looks very complex but the theory behind
this isn't that it's too complex let's
just imagine that we have some work
that's happening somewhere else this
could be loading a file from disk or
something like that when that work is
done i want to continue with some work
and i want to do that on the ui thread
now
that sounds all good because we saw that
this dispatcher that use is using wpf to
communicate back with the ui thread
works really well
but then at the bottom here i also say
that
i want to block until all of this is
done
so until this entire operation is done
because i'm adding the weight here after
this continue with that means that this
continuation or this task needs to
complete
before i do anything else if i block the
ui thread
how would this be able to complete
because it cannot communicate back to
the ui thread so therefore we have a
crash
now this seems like it's very complex
and you wouldn't write code like this
who would ever write deadlocking code
like this here well
there's an easier way to achieve the
same idea
and that's simply to call dot weight
or the method weight or result on an
asynchronous
method so how come this whoops sorry how
come this this crashes the application
i hinted this just a moment ago
let's go into visual studio
and i'll show you
let's change this method back to
method body doesn't matter
unless i still have a throw exception
i'll have to get rid of that
so if i change this back to async void
sorry
missing task
instead of doing a wait here
if i want to to wait for this work to be
done
let's do this just to make it super
obvious
do something
and
wait
so it looks like i want to take an
asynchronous operation and i want to
make it synchronous in some cases you
might have an application that you
really don't want anything to be running
asynchronously you want to wait for that
result you have no way of increasing
async and weight all the way in your
application so therefore you have to use
weight
the problem here is that
this here is going to block the ui
thread and i said earlier that all the
code inside do something
this here is executed on the ui thread
so if i block the ui thread how would it
be able to do all of this work how would
this
task ever be able to complete
if it cannot update the ui
so obviously if i run this with a
debugger
a word of warning if you run this
without a debugger you have to find the
process and kill it yourself
so look at that the application totally
crashed
and when it comes to deadlocks windows
never seems to understand that it
crashed
because it's just waiting forever
right so
i have to kill the application
it makes sense now that we know that the
async keyword just moves things into a
state machine and the state machine is
still executing a ui thread blocking the
state machine from executing means i
have no way of waiting for that work to
be done
so how if i really want to do this
obviously there's always a way to do
things you want
so i can say task
i can say task.run
let's run do something
so this here let's run this and see if
it actually works before i say that it
does
i click run here
it was an exception somewhere in this
this
did i throw an exception
yes
all right
the reason there's an exception is
because i try to update the ui from
somewhere else
let's run it without a debugger
so what happened here the application
crashes and that's good
because what i did here was that i moved
the entire state machine to a different
thread
so now what i did here is that i said
run do something somewhere else
block the ui until that work on the
other thread is completed so it runs the
state machine it keeps track of all the
asynchronous operations on a completely
different thread and then i'm blocking
the ui until that is done
but then
this this method here internally has a
lot of ui interactions and that won't be
possible because it's from a different
thread right
so that's why you'll end up
sorry that's why you'll end up getting
an exception so you'd have to handle
that accordingly as well
so if you really want to block an
asynchronous operation you have to first
wrap that in a separate task
but if it has ui interactions that will
fail and if you try to
marshal those those calls or if you have
to introduce the dispatcher inside this
do something method you'll end up with
another deadlock
so be very careful
the same goes for for calling the result
property on a task if it's not already
completed that would also result in a
deadlock
so how do we avoid deadlocks well
obviously we should never use weight or
result
we can use weight or result if we know
that we are inside the continuation
but only after the await keyword or
inside a continue with method
and you shouldn't confuse there's two
methods very similar named you have
task.wait all and task.when all don't
confuse these two methods
it might seem like you want to
to wait to run the next line of code but
that's not really what you want
you want to continue with the next line
of code
so it's a little bit of a
different wording that you'd use
and another things to to have in mind is
you shouldn't share locks if you have
locks in the application
or lock objects you shouldn't share them
between different asynchronous contexts
that will also ensure that you have a
deadlock
all right so there's one more thing i
want to talk about in terms of the state
machine and that's we want to avoid
introducing unnecessary code because i
mentioned at the start of this talk i
said that especially on android or ios
or mobile devices
you want to avoid having too much code
that has to be executed because each
line of code requires cpu power cpu
power requires battery and that's
people hate you for building
applications that drain battery so we
want to build efficient applications and
that sometimes means we shouldn't use
async in a weight because we don't
always have to
so in this example here
i have a method called run async it
awaits some internal
method which is also marked as async
which is then also awaiting something
this isn't too
too uncommon that you have a long method
call inside a really big enterprise
application where this happens
it's not too uncommon
and
someone once said you should you should
use async and weight all the way sorry
you should use async and await all the
way you should do
asynchronous should be
a synchronous principle should be used
all the way through the chain of your
method calls but that doesn't
necessarily mean adding async await
everywhere it just means that you
shouldn't block anywhere inside that
chain you shouldn't use result or weight
or anything like that
the
the basic idea here is that if you don't
need to do anything inside the
continuation
you don't need to use async in a weight
let me show you why
so i have an application here
which is which is doing exactly this
it's pretty much the similar similar
application
it has an asynchronous method which
calls an internal asynchronous method
which then calls something else there's
a lot of async and await all the way
through this entire application
now if i compile this
and have a look at the generated code
we can see here that this in fact
generates
a couple of different state machines
and this is a lot of code that's
generated for
a very simple application or a very
simple concept
and if we look at the
the actual code that was generated
there's a lot of code in here that we do
we really need all of this code
generated or running for each of those
different methods
so for every method you mark as async
you're going to get one of these classes
generated that holds a state machine
right
and for for iot devices and for mobile
phones that's a little bit unnecessary
so how do we approach this how do we
solve this how can we improve this
application to make the the chain of
method calls a little bit more efficient
well we can still adhere to the same
contract
as i mentioned earlier we can just
add the async keyword that just
automatically returns a task
that goes the other way around as well
if i have a task that returned from a
method
couldn't i just remove the async keyword
and instead return this
and i still have the same contract i
haven't broken anything in the
application and all of a sudden i
reduced one class that's been generated
and if i do this for for all of these
different methods
let's go to let's take the bottom one
first so i want to remove async from
this here
but there's also a little bit more of an
efficient way of doing
doing this here
what happens here is that i have two
calls to two different let's say
websites
take 500 milliseconds each wouldn't it
be better to execute both of these at
the same time
because it doesn't look like they were
actually related so they don't rely on
each other
to do that
we can use something called task dot
when all
and i can simply pass a
an array of tasks that i want to execute
and it will run all of them at the same
time and tell you when all of them are
done
so i could just return this
so this here is now a reference to
two asynchronous operations and when
both of them are done
the task that this returns will be
marked as completed
right so that's one more state machine
that's that's removed
and we can do the same for all of them
just remove the async and our keywords
right and it will all work and we could
even i believe we could do the same here
right so we have
a continuation
i can probably just return that task
because it really references oops sorry
it really references
both of those operations
all right so i just replaced the async
and away keyword by removing the async
and replacing the await with a return
and this doesn't work for all different
cases
sometimes you have to use the async away
keyword when you're doing for instance
an http call you can just return the get
async task that wouldn't work you have
to await that same goes for database
operations you have to complete them and
and await them inside where inside the
method where you called it but now
when i
refresh this application i
would compile this and look at this here
there's no longer
a lot of generated code instead it's
just the method parties that performs a
method call
and just returns the task there's no
more
overhead in terms of generated code and
things that has to run right
so sometimes the right approach is to
not introduce async in a weight
sometimes you can just return the task
but it's really important that at the
top level
that would be inside in this case the
main thing that or the main method that
executes this program that's where you
have the await that's what awaiting or
using async and a weight all the way
means at the top level or at some level
in the application you have to validate
the entire chain of method calls
but unless there's anything inside the
continuation you don't have to do the
async and away keywords
so async can await
or sorry async all the way means that
you should avoid introducing unnecessary
state machines or unnecessary async
methods but you should await at the top
level that could be the main method or
in the click event handler for example
all right
then i guess the the idea of how do i
cancel one of these tasks because i have
a long method of for a long chain of
asynchronous operations how do i make
sure that if i want to be able to cancel
this summer in the application how do i
do that
task doesn't really have anything in in
terms of
just knowing exactly how to terminate
itself you can't just tell a task to hey
i want you to cancel you can't just pass
what's known as the cancellation token
and think that it's going to work out of
the box you have to write some manual
code to handle that because you don't
know in which portion of your
asynchronous operation this cancellation
would occur
and if you cancel an operation do you
want partial data do you want to roll
back or what do you want to do with that
you have to handle all of those
different situations yourself
let's say i have this method called
long running operation
this is a while true loop that just
prints something out to to a window here
it writes the ticks to a debug window
and then just has a way to test a delay
if i run this
using a task.run as you'll see here
i'm going to pass something called a
cancellation token
the tank the cancellation token source
is something that allows me to signal
that i want to cancel on asynchronous
operation
and i can pass the token into this this
synchronous operation but when i then
say that i want to cancel this
nothing is going to happen
because how would this method know how
to handle this this here is executed on
a different thread if i tell this to
cancel how would it know where to stop
it wouldn't it wouldn't make sense for
this to just automatically know where to
cancel itself
so instead
you have to introduce a little bit of
code to
handle that properly in this case here i
say that if someone has requested a
cancellation i want to throw an
exception
and then i can handle that properly
maybe i need to roll back this last
portion of the code maybe i need to
send some signal somewhere else or do
something
so
keep that in mind because this is
something that buys a lot of developers
quite frequently and then handling how
to approach that in different situations
what happens if you cancel or the
cancellation happens at the top or at
the bottom is that going to behave
differently is that going to change the
behavior of how you handle that
potential cancellation
right so another in terms of efficiency
asynchronous operations with databases
is really important like when you want
to load data that's one of the main
places where you want to
to introduce the synchronous programming
is when you talk to your databases or
when you talk to your web apis
when it comes to to energy framework
it doesn't support parallel operations
on the same context so for for those
situations you should always use the
await keyword on each of those different
asynchronous operations using entity
framework if you try to be smart here
and optimize this yourself you're going
to run into situations where it doesn't
work as expected so always await your
your calls to your database when it
comes to asynchronous or when it comes
to entity framework
so the final thing i want to talk about
is how to stream data if you read my
c-sharp talk yesterday you saw an
example of how to stream data
using asynchronous principles
and this is done by introducing
something called an i-async enumerable
this allows us to
to consume a stream of data
asynchronously
let's say that i might be getting
something from the disk or i might be
getting something from the web or maybe
i'm listening to an mqtt
server and i'm listening for data to be
fed into my application
and i can then use an asynchronous
enumerable to do that
let me show you an example of this
it's harder to exit powerpoint than it
is to work with asynchronous programming
let's see here
i have an application here it's a wpf
application again
i've introduced a method here called get
lyrics it's an iasync innumerable of
string so this will stream strings into
my my wpf application
what i've also added here is that the
capability of cancelling this operation
wherever i want and i've decorated this
with an attribute called enumerator
cancellation this allows me to to set
the cancellation token in a little bit
of a different manner than you might not
have instead of passing it into the
method yourself
and i'll show you that when we consume
this method
inside this method
i'm opening a stream to a file on my
disk
i'm simply saying that i want to load
some lines using asynchronous principles
so notice here that it's marked as async
i use the iasync enumerable this is a
task like thing so it knows exactly what
to do when it sees the async keyword
together with the i async enumerable
i have the weight keyword say that i
want to load each line seriously
and then if there's a cancellation i'm
going to throw an exception so whoever
uses or consumes this stream of data
they can handle that properly
then i process each lines it takes about
400 milliseconds before i use yield
return
to signal that
i've now asynchronously processed a line
or a result you can now go ahead and
handle that
it's important to know here that we have
no idea how many lines there are here so
in terms of writing efficient code and
writing code that might not fail
you never want to call to array on your
enumerables or your iasync enumerables
because you don't know how much data
there is going to be
right so when i consume this
let's have a look at how we do that
here's a for each loop that has an await
in front of it this looks a bit
different from what you might have seen
in the past normally when you have an
asynchronous method
you have the await keyword in front of
the method call to say run this method
and once there's a result available i
want you to come back to this particular
portion of the code but in this case
here the await keyword is in front of
the for each loop because what we're
saying here is that each line that comes
out of this method called git lyrics is
going to be asynchronously retrieved
so effectively what happens here is that
this here is a continuation
each time we have some data that's being
passed back from that asynchronous
operation
we're going to run this code back on the
ui thread
that's a big difference as well from
using the task parallel library after
the await keyword all code is always
executed on the original thread that's a
really important difference between
using the task parallel library and the
async can await
and then you see here that i have this
method called with cancellation this is
what's passed into that
the decorated attribute the enumerate
enumerator cancellation because maybe i
don't own this this method call maybe
this i async enumerable is a property or
it's coming from somewhere else so i can
pass in the cancellation using this
method call
all right so if i run this here
see if it works
where is my ui
here we go run
perfect
i worked
best song in the world
all right let's press cancel here and
hopefully that worked as well
cancel
and the operation was cancelled as well
so it handled that cancellation properly
so these iasync enumerables are really
powerful to get data streamed into your
application and you can use this in many
different interesting and cool
situations to make your applications
work
a lot more efficiently when it comes to
a lot of data that needs to be processed
just keep in mind that you should never
ask for it to be converted into an array
because that
is going to take a lot of time and
processing power
i have a whole course so if you have
four hours to spare
i i'm going to detail in a lot of about
asynchronous programming
there's really much to cover when it
comes to both parallel programming and
asynchronous programming
and if you like that course i have about
20 more so if you have like a few weeks
to spare like if you want to learn about
game programming in python or the latest
in c sharp go ahead and check my
pluralsight courses
and again i hope you found this really
useful i want to thank you so much for
listening to me if you have any
questions about async and await or
anything in c sharp feel free to reach
out thank you again for having me here
it's been a pleasure
[Applause]
so
you